disney's alice in wonderland is a
magical journey into nonsense
but for all the childish delight this
classic animated movie has to offer
it also has a more grown up side from
its philosophical origins to its love of
the psychedelic
these are things only adults notice in
alice in wonderland
if you watch alice in wonderland as a
grown up it becomes
immediately apparent just how
unsupervised alice actually is
although her sister appears to be old
enough to look out for the both of them
the lack of any parental presence
throughout the course of the film
might prompt you to wonder just where
all the responsible adults are supposed
to be
when the film hit theaters in the early
1950s in fact
until relatively recently free-range
children were the norm
rather than the exception kids used to
be told to play outside with other
neighborhood children and come home when
the street lights came on
entire hours would go by where the only
parent any kid encountered was mother
nature
and while the modernization of society
generally comes with its improvement
modern times also have their own
problems and challenges
thanks to everything from infectious
diseases to advancements in computing
kids nowadays generally spend more time
inside than their predecessors
for better or for worse either way alice
certainly has the edge on modern
youngsters here
and maybe it's not so surprising that
she finds it so easy to wander off the
beaten path
before you put pen to paper lewis
carroll's stories originated as oral
tales he would regale to colleagues and
their children
while boating between oxford and
woodstock two locations rooted deep in
english history eager to entertain older
minds as well as younger ones
carol took inspiration from his
surroundings and his experiences in
higher education
layering them into his stories as they
developed
a palpable sense of childish fancy is
plainly apparent in his stories but they
are also laden with subtle hints at more
mature subjects
including riddles in numbers games
critical thinking philosophy
and local history disney's alice in
wonderland begins with alice's older
sister reading her excerpts from some of
that history this scene even features
quotes from a real-life historical text
javelin chapnal's short course of
history
and even stigand the archbishop of
canterbury
agreed to meet with william and offer
him the crown
this same passage makes an appearance in
lewis carroll's novel
in fact the book was studied by alice
liddell one of carol's dearest child
friends and the real life inspiration
for
alice in wonderland throughout his life
carol was friends with the children of
his colleagues
which was actually pretty normal for a
victorian bachelor
but the nature of these friendships and
carol's sexual identity has long been a
hotbed of debate among scholars
interestingly the chosen excerpt is from
a chapter examining the rise and fall
of the house of normandy an era of
history rife with noble women and
princesses who were named alice
sharper eyes will note a distinctive
tower shape in the background of the
opening and closing scenes of
alice in wonderland which has left many
kids wondering if alice lives in a
castle
in fact this is none other than christ
church cathedral
on the grounds of the prestigious oxford
university
in which carol lived studied and worked
for his entire adult life
before he was an author lewis carroll
was known best by his birth name
charles lutwidge dawson he was a
brilliant mathematician
and inventor devoted scholar and deacon
of the anglican church
all of which would influence his fiction
later in life
james joyce salvador dali numerous video
game and comic book creators and of
course
walt disney have all been influenced by
carol's work
as a further homage to alice in
wonderland's life origins and influences
a rowboat can be spotted in a pond in
the first scene
this was thoughtfully placed as a homage
to the camaraderie-filled boat rides
which helped inspire
carol's fictional works as a kid
watching alice in wonderland is a simple
whimsical trip
into a world of technicolor fantasy as
an adult however
one can't help but derive deeper meaning
from what might otherwise seem like
nonsense
particularly with regards to psychology
and philosophy
alice's adventures begin the moment she
trails her fingers across the surface of
a garden pond
and its reflection appears the white
rabbit running late
as ever this imagery and her ensuing
fall down the rabbit hole
has been interpreted as symbolizing the
unconscious mind
which can only be accessed via dreams
trances or other similar states
hidden within the unconscious mind
according to some psychologists and
philosophers
are all the unknown aspects of oneself
including repressed urges
fears traumas and beliefs dreaming is
one way for the unconscious mind to
communicate with the conscious mind
particularly when one is undergoing a
psychological imbalance
that can be harmful to one's well-being
sort of like how a car's check engine
lights alert its owners to issues they
might otherwise miss
carl young called these revelatory
visions big dreams
and dedicated his life to the study and
interpretation
of symbolic dream imagery likewise the
dream imagery in alice in wonderland has
not gone
unnoticed by academics and continues to
be studied and discussed
to this day while older viewers will
notice a prolific use of dream symbolism
in alice in wonderland
others hold a very different and far
more controversial
perspective on the story's imagery that
alice is actually
under the influence of mind-altering
substances
throughout the course of the film alice
consumes a variety of beverages
pastries and even mushrooms all of which
alter her perspective by causing her to
grow or shrink
in size the use of mushrooms in
particular spurs this theory on
which was initially popularized by the
counter culture movement of the 1960s
most famously the psychedelic rock band
jefferson airplanes stoked the fires
of this theory with the release of their
1967 hit
white rabbit a song which makes explicit
reference to pills
hookah smoking and being off your head
this track became an iconic anthem of
60s counterculture and ushered in a slew
of similar interpretations from other
artists and authors
including go ask alice a fictional
account of a teen girl spiral into
addiction
ironically lewis carroll has no
documented history of pervasive drug use
and all indications are that he would
actually be rather appalled by this
interpretation
many animation studios including disney
have become notorious for layering adult
humor into their films
and alice in wonderland is no exception
early in the movie
alice finds herself stuck inside the
white rabbit's house
after nibbling on a pastry which makes
her grow to monstrous proportions
in an effort to prevent this from
happening the rabbit runs into the house
and back out again when alice grows too
large
sharp eyes following his path will note
a family portrait lining the stairs
but this is no ordinary domestic
depiction whereas your average family
unit is composed of a handful of people
there are so many children and other
relations pictured in the rabbit's
family that one
single frame runs the entire length of
the stairs
the kids won't pick up on it but older
viewers will be more than aware
that this is a sneaky risque reference
to the phrase
multiplying like rabbits golden
afternoon is one of the most beautiful
songs from alice in wonderland
this delightful sing-along is shared
with alice by a group of anthropomorphic
flowers
the gorgeous scenery they provide makes
this a high point of the movie
that is until the flowers take a
shocking turn
in their attitudes curious about their
unexpected guest's origins
they ask alice what kind of garden she
comes from but when she explains she
doesn't come from a garden
her new friends assume she has more
uncouth origins
as a wildflower and their attitudes take
a very dark turn
indeed they then go on to criticize
alice with rude statements clearly meant
to cause her emotional distress
over her physical appearance just look
at those stems
rather scrawny i'd say when a sweet
natured baby rosebud remarks that she
thinks alice is pretty
her mother tells her to be quiet while
covering her mouth
the turbulence gets kicked up even more
when alice declares she's not
a flower at all which drives the others
to assume she is
quote nothing more than a common weed
this assumption stirs them into a frenzy
eager to shoe alice away before she goes
to seed
and spreads weeds and their bed alice is
right when she declares these flowers
could learn a few things about manners
of course
and whether this is taken as a reference
to class snobbery
alice's rebelliousness or even body
shaming 21st century adults will know
better that what those flowers are
saying
just isn't cool for as long as humans
have existed
we have marveled over the puzzling
nature of who we are and how we came to
be
this is a deeply complex question of
course and basically every culture in
human history
has developed its own theories in an
attempt to answer it
on the surface alice's encounter with
the hookah smoking caterpillar is merely
a string of silly puns
likewise his insistence on asking alice
who she is could easily be
interpreted as a simple question from
one stranger to another
however some viewers might note hints of
eastern philosophy present in the
caterpillar's character
schools of thought and religions from
the far east like taoism
and buddhism often interrogate concepts
of an individual self separate from the
divine
instead many believe the sensation of
self is a hallucination
and hold to the philosophy that all
beings are manifestations of a single
energy source consider zen coans which
are thought exercises
often in the form of stories or riddles
that are designed to break the student
out of stagnant ways of thinking and
stimulate enlightenment
sound familiar if you ask me you
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
since animation has permeated popular
culture over the last century
viewers have come to identify characters
by the sound of their voice
just as much as their outward appearance
and thanks to the many talented actors
who have turned to voice acting over the
years
these characters are brought to life in
ways that transcend
the written word some voice actors are
true masters of their craft
capable of portraying dozens of
characters for various features in their
lifetimes each with a unique voice and
cadence
one of those legendary talents was the
great sterling holloway who voice acted
in more than 100 radio programs
tv shows and animated films during a
prolific career spanning nearly five
decades
sterling took on numerous projects for
disney during that time
voicing iconic characters like sleepy
and snow white and the seven dwarfs
winnie the pooh and even the cheshire
cat and alice in wonderland
it's easy to miss as a kid but adult
ears will find sterling's unique
tinny rasp very easy to identify just
wanted to ask you which way i ought to
go
well that depends on where
you want to get to during the climax to
alice in wonderland alice finds herself
in the red queen's kingdom
and to her dismay alice quickly learns
that this royal ruler has some serious
anger
issues switching between a calm ladylike
demeanor
and maniacal serial killer level wrath
the red queen carries her weight around
with all the grace of an elephant in a
glassware shop
the fear of the queen is so deeply
instilled in her subjects in fact
that alice finds anthropomorphic playing
cards painting white roses red
because they accidentally planted the
wrong color when the queen catches them
in the act
she demands their death by execution
with one of the story's most
iconic lines with their hands
this phrase is a notable favorite of the
red queen who expresses
a repeated desire to kill her own people
and then there are the numerous acts of
animal cruelty
in a twisted version of croquet the
queen uses live animals in place of
traditional equipment
flamingos replace mallets hedgehogs are
used in place of balls and playing cards
replace hoops
it's all pretty dark stuff even for
alice in wonderland
and as an adult it's hard not to feel
particularly bad for the red queen's
subjects
thankfully alice escapes the red queen's
rage returning home
safe and sound by awaking from what
appears to be a dream
or so it seems check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss
a single one